i dans l'est de la Libye le bilan
s'alourdit de jour en jour 11300 morts
selon le Croissant Rouge libyen auquel
s'ajoute 10000 personnes porté disparu
la présidente de la Commission
européenne Orsola von derleyen et pour
sa parelle déjà arrivée elle s'est
rendue à Lampedusa au côté de la chef du
gouvernement italien le
pyoman vient sur les lieux de l'incendie
et fait passer pour un pompier
immigration illégale est un enjeu
européen qui a besoin d'une réponse
globale et je demande aux autres pays
européens d'accueillir une partie des
migrants arrivés ici en Italie Madame
Van derleyen le 15 septembre c'est de
jours je cite nous avons besoin d'une
immigration de main d'œuvre je crois
qu'il y a vous avez dit 11000 arrivant
je crois qu'il y a 6 7000 habitants sur
cette petite
île ça ne s'appelle pas une immigration
ça s'pp elle pas même une submersion ça
s'appelle une invasion donc Madame V
derlyen impose cette localisation de
migrant dans nos pays contre la volonté
des peuples européens et le peuple
français aura la possibilité de dire non
le 9 juin prochain la h son propos qu'
tient souvenez-vous il y a quelques mois
moment de la victoire de Madame mon elle
expliquait que l'Italie avait ENIT un
Cho courageux en se tournant vers la
droite vers l'extrême droite ce qui
montre que c'est pas la solution miracle
parce que ça n'empêche une partie des
c'est le fiasco
complet